as the latest addition to nbc's ever
expanding library of sitcoms young rock
has already taken the television world
by storm
in case you haven't seen it the story of
young rock goes like this
dwayne the rock johnson is running for
president but wants to better connect
with the people in hopes of securing
their vote
to do so he joins one division's own
randall park to shed some light on the
man behind the myth
telling crazy stories from his childhood
sharing life lessons that got him
through hard times and
showing there's more to him than meets
the eye
oh and i've got some pretty cool stories
about andre the giant
with one episode released so far there's
no denying the former scorpion king
actor went through quite an
unorthodox upbringing the rock's
developmental years proved rather
unconventional
his father the late soul man rocky
johnson made ends meet by working as a
professional wrestler and as a
consequence kept his family on the road
most of the year
as a byproduct of that lifestyle the
young dwayne johnson aka
dewey spent a lot of time around his
dad's co-workers
including the likes of the iron chic
junkyard dog
and the eighth wonder of the world
himself andre the giant
you know when you grow up around
wrestlers sometimes you learn lessons in
very interesting ways casting such a
larger than life character for young
rock surely wasn't easy but
matthew willig ultimately landed the
role here's where else you might
recognize the massive actor from
born and raised in la mirada california
matthew willig grew up playing sports
particularly basketball and football he
carried this interest into his college
years where he played football at the
university of southern california
playing a role on the winning team of
the 1989 rose bowl
this success didn't go unnoticed
inevitably leading to willick joining
the national football league in 1993
as an offensive tackle for the new york
jets he played with the jets until 1995
when he was scooped by the atlanta
falcons who kept him around for two
seasons
afterwards he signed with the green bay
packers in 1998 followed by the saint
louis rams in 1999.
he didn't actually see any playing time
that season but his team did get the
victory at super bowl 34 earning himself
a super bowl ring
as the 2000s began willig found himself
on the roster of the san francisco 49ers
he stayed with the team until 2002 when
he jumped to the carolina panthers
the team that sent him back to the super
bowl for the 38th
big game he wrapped up his nfl career
after the 2005 season
once again as a member of the st louis
rams it's an epic career in a position
that boasts an average lifespan of about
three and a half years in the pros but
even after retirement willig was just
getting started
on the football field being a six foot
eight inch mountain of a man certainly
has its benefits
when it comes to the bright lights of
hollywood however it also provides a
kind of niche
willig's big screen tenure kicked off in
1993 in action movie full contact
playing the aptly named character of
hulk years later
after his nfl career had run its course
williek popped up in the 2006 sports
comedy the benchwarmers as an unnamed
jock
establishing a trend of taking minor
roles that play to his unique frame
willik put this asset to use for comedy
sake in 2009 for the prehistoric jack
black and michael cera project
year one portraying the burly marlak a
proficient hunter who's more than
capable of manhandling jack black's
character
his next most high profile gig arrived
in 2013
once again working in the comedic realm
for we're the millers
acting as a menacing drug dealer
alongside jason sedakis and jennifer
aniston
in 2015 he tried his hand at more
dramatic fare appearing as deceased
football star justin strelzik in the
biographical sports drama
concussion three years later he teamed
up with the coen brothers for a small
part in the ballad of buster scruggs
striking an intimidating posture in a
role credited as
cantina scum his most recent cinematic
works
include a role in heavy metal icon rob
zombie's 2019 horror film
three from hell followed by a small part
in 2020's
birds of prey of course these examples
are only a small portion of his entire
filmography which also includes
lesser-known releases like short films
and direct to video movies
even in those smaller projects he
obviously has a tendency to stand out
2006 marked the beginning of his
television work
that year he made one-off appearances on
malcolm in the middle the west wing and
everybody hates chris the next year he
appeared in two episodes of dexter
and he also made appearances on ncis and
the young and the restless
with the 2010s in full swing willig's tv
workflow held strong
bringing him parts and shows such as
grimm brooklyn nine-nine
and agents of shield on which he played
the role of the inhuman lash for six
installments of the show's third season
aside from his role on young rock his
more recent credits include two episodes
of flaked and three of blunt talk as
well as a cameo
on the guest book in 2018 and charmed in
2019. the guys clearly got the frame for
genre
for now willigg is expected to continue
appearing in the first season of young
rock
considering his lengthy resume and his
unique physicality it's hard to imagine
he'll be dropping off the radar anytime
soon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you